let's say we're going to reboot the
franchise back to the future let's just
think about how we would do that right
and it's a female back to the future
sure and marty
her name is mandy right and she goes
back
why are there so many bad sequels
there are so many bad sequels because i
feel like the essence
of what made the original
so interesting is the thing that's not
really focused on
usually what's focused on in a sequel is
more
and it's more spectacle not the thing
that made it compelling to begin with
i think the way to answer this question
is to look at the sequels that
that you know succeeded um
films like the godfather two right
godfather two
you know was an even more complex film
than the original godfather
it tells it it plays with time where
you're having
two stories being told simultaneously
the story of vito corleone
his rise to power uh you know along with
you know the pre the present-day michael
corleone
who's you know you're seeing his story
play out in
present day that the story is being told
um and it's also
different and it's original in the same
way that the first godfather was
original
i could apply that same thing to star
wars and the empire strikes back
the empire strikes back ended on a
cliffhanger the original star wars ended
with this triumphant
ending the good guys win when did the
good guys ever lose
in a fairy tale generally never
but the empire strikes back did that it
didn't even tell a complete story
you know and at the time you had to wait
three years to to
see what the conclusion of that story
would be so
doing something original and different
rather than more of the same
which would have been let's have another
death star which of course they did
twice more in star wars films
you know i mean maybe three times if you
want to count rogue one
but going over old territory
is boring and i feel like what you need
to do is in the same way
that the original film was a risk in
doing something original
if you're going to do a sequel you also
need to take
risks and do something different
i would i would say that um this doesn't
apply as much but with alien and
aliens um alien directed by ridley scott
um aliens uh james cameron
one's more horror set in outer space the
other one is action movie
more aliens right but it's a different
type of film
um and a continuation of that story told
um with with some originality that's
another sequel that holds up
but so many other sequels that i have
not named
are terrible for the very reason that
they just
try to give you more of what was in the
first one rather than
you know defy your expectations
and and that i think has to do with
fear on the part of the filmmakers and
not really
trusting the audience i think you need
to trust the audience that
they want to see these beloved
characters from the first
film in new and different situations
things that are challenging to those
characters
and and you don't often see that in
sequels
it's just more
i think that's lazy as much as the fast
and the furious movies are financially
successful
i don't know if you could call any of
them
critically acclaimed those films tend to
do well
but it's just more craziness
it's more over the top it's more
in the last one they go to outer space
how much more over the top can you get
it's just it's ridiculous
now i mean at this point just take you
know a friend of mine once suggested
just take the drivers from fast and the
furious and put them
in the transformers cars they're driving
the transformers cars
why not combine franchises it would at
least be original
right but i i think if you're going to
do a sequel
you've got to do something different and
original because that's
keeping with the characters and you need
to challenge the characters in ways they
were not challenged in the first film
and i'm not saying that's something easy
but when you look at what a successful
sequel is
compared to one that is completely
forgettable
they made of the fly too the fly with
jeff goldblum they made a sequel to it
gina davis's character dies in like the
opening scene no one
there's many sequels i could i could
name off the top of my head you would
not even remember
that there was a sequel the highland
highlander two
there was a sequel i think there's like
nine of those
but the only one that really holds up is
the first one
so it's it's very tricky it's very
tricky i i feel like
it's important to to
be original in the same way that the
first one what what people liked about
that
flip that defy expectations i'll go back
several decades but uh staying alive
and saturday night fever and i know i'm
really dating myself here but
both fantastic films staying alive to me
um i'm sorry yeah staying alive was was
a little bit better in my sense than
than saturday night fever just because i
enjoyed
john travolta's journey staying in this
crummy hotel
he's this hungry dancer he meets finola
hughes who's got this upper hand
and can help him but there are strings
attached it's just a fantastic
cast of characters and to me i thought
that the the storytelling was
was richer but again that's it's going
back several years it's not a franchise
i understand that
some of the viewers may not know that
movie but uh i thought that the
storytelling was
was way better but i yeah do you
remember that
i remember it and uh i wish i could
forget it
oh you do okay it was that bad no um it
just
that i mean that film i just remember
the phenomenon being the music
i remember it was rated and i could not
go see it
so okay you know at the the time that
the
uh saturday night fever came out sure
sure yes i think i remember that too but
i think i saw it when i was a little bit
older
but the staying alive
for me just i thought that the
continuation of his journey as this like
you know here he was this hot shot back
home
but then he goes to the big city and
he's just this small fish in this
very very treacherous pond where no
one's trustworthy
and everybody has their own agenda and
the girl the good girl cynthia gibbs
she actually seems like the best care
and he's like whatever with you because
she can't
she can't get him anywhere so i just
thought it was just a great play on
on things but yeah i i realize it's not
a franchise um
that's a great cameo from sylvester
stallone in the beginning by the way so
i mean look here's here's here's another
reason
to me that sequels tend to suck is that
the first film generally is
is made to not be a series the first
film is
is is being made to tell a story and
it's usually
being made for a reason that this is
there's there's meaning behind it
there's purpose on
on behalf of the filmmaker that wants to
tell a story
that has themes that are woven into the
film that that the filmmaker wants to
express
so generally an original film
that ends up being a you know part of a
series
unintentionally you know
that that original film is being made
out of some
reason that that is artistic
and sequels are made for money so by
you know by that very you know because
of that dynamic
sequels are made for money original
films
that end up being part of a series are
usually made to express
something an artist is trying to say um
that always mucks up what a sequel will
be
interestingly yes i am
going to come back to star wars george
lucas
um had alan dean foster come up with a
story for
a low-budget independent sequel to star
wars which
was to be called splinter of the mind's
eye
um it's it ended up being a novel
you can find it used in a bookstore
yeah a bookstore probably a used
bookstore
you know go into one they're great
books are these things it's like the
internet but on really thin slices of
wood
try it someday in any case this book was
written to be a low budget
sequel to star wars because what george
lucas wanted to do is
you know if star wars bombed he wanted
to make a small
indie follow-up to that movie to
continue the series
and he wanted it written in a way that
that could be done
inexpensively it's really interesting to
see what
what star wars might have been if
splinter the mind's
eye was made as a low-budget indie movie
um
there's love to see a lot of those but
but but
but you know i i truly believe that
sequels because they are made
purely because accountants at a studio
say
this will make money because if it makes
of the original it'll be in profits if
we scale the budget to this
which is why the budgets generally for
sequels
are less money being spent than the
original
you know because there is a formula used
by studios
to say well the movie made x the first
movie made x
if we scale the budget to this
and it just makes even 40 of the
original
will be in profits um
you know that old formula is different
these days now with
um uh with so many other pathways for
films to make money but
but generally the sequel the budget is
less
did you see wonder woman 1984
yes i saw wonder woman 1984. okay
first off did you used to watch the show
i did i did used to watch the linda
carter show
and i love that show okay uh it's it's
it's fun it's you know it's wholesome
um there's a weird subtext i didn't
notice when i was a kid but now i see it
if you know something about the history
of wonder woman and that character
but uh but yes i saw wonder woman and i
did see wonder woman 1984.
is this pg-13 can you tell me the
subtext well it's all about
it's all about bdsm and fetish stuff it
was always like
wonder woman getting tied up or wonder
woman tying up with the lasso
gotcha you know whoever the adversary
was to make them tell the truth
okay it was um this is not an original
thought of mine this is all
very well documented go down your own
rabbit hole on the internet but uh
feel free to jump off okay at some point
so aside from the s
m angle to it um which that's its own
show
what what do you what do you think uh
fell short
in 1984 the second i think what fell
short was
was logic on behalf of the filmmakers i
mean they really there was a
the thing that really fell short was a
believability
um you know you can wish things and they
come true
i think it's kind of a maybe an idea
that should have been vetted it
sounds kind of sounds kind of dumb to me
like it just i just didn't believe it
whereas yeah i believe
a woman who's an amazonian could be
imbued with these powers but wonder
woman isn't wonder woman because of her
powers
she's because of her because of her
character and her morality
um because of her commitment
to you know defending those that are
powerless you know against the from the
powerful
and i feel that that essence of her
character was kind of captured maybe a
little bit in the opening scene
which i thought was kind of cute and
clever and and the opening scene of
wonder woman 84 is kind of harking back
to
a richard donner superman you know
i i i enjoyed that it was kind of cute
and goofy
i'll take it it's fine once it got into
the the main plot with
uh pedro pascal it just sort of defied
logic and and the the way that
that uh you know you know
chris pine's character was brought back
it was i just thought was ridiculous i i
don't
i don't know if the gender was reversed
it was done the other way it might have
worked it might even be somewhat
offensive
you know sort of like if they made a
female back to the future
let's say if they they rebooted the
franchise let's say we're going to
reboot the franchise back to the future
let's just think about how we would do
that right
and it's a female back to the future
sure and marty
her name is mandy right and she goes
back
and there's a sexual tension between her
dad or who will be her dad
a younger version of her dad i don't
think that will work
yeah that's a little creepy it's a
little creepy
so maybe it's a really good thing
it's a good thing that back to the
future franchise may be one of the only
franchises
that will not be rebooted because if you
did reboot
back to the future with a female mandy
right and well i guess it could be doc
brown
um not gonna work it just doesn't work
sure please hollywood realize that it's
not going to work because we've seen
these franchises get rebooted
and it's disheartening to me when you
see the number of movies
made it's always based on pre-existing
material
and the reason hollywood does this is
because ideas must be vetted in some
form
it was a play it was a novel it's a
franchise which is
generally the answer it's a franchise
that's existed for
80 years 50 years 40 years whatever it
is right like
it's vetted if you're going to invest
that kind of money
you know it's just it's you know
you want to make sure you have your best
chance of being profitable
so i understand from their thinking
but it really does it does quell
what might be some amazing original
ideas that's why
i i i i'm upset that we may never see a
type of filmmaker
like george lucas again of creating a
fantasy world from nothing
as an original series of movies
i mean star wars was certainly inspired
by
everything from marvel comics dr doom's
character darth vader
um from flash gordon uh the
serials um from uh dune
the book by frank herbert uh
it was inspired by so many things it's
like a blender of all this cool
into something that's original
and risk is not
something hollywood likes
you